herzlich willkommen zu einem häufigen
video heute zusammen mit kelly das wort
zum wir haben beide wieder harry potter
sachen an bzw
gryffindor sachverstand liebe hab
eigentlich habe der test sagt was
anderswo gutgläubig wurde glaubt jetzt
erfolge das ist super nein dass sie
loyal zeit ich schick dir mal so ein
video der rohling überwachung habe
gepasst
die beste hauses und es macht total sind
locker und setzt dann will ich hoffe
passt aber noch bis 2
ich bin auf jeden fall letztens über
unser gemeinsames video wo wir in harry
potter quiz gemacht haben gestolpert und
dachte mir wir müssen noch mal irgendwas
mit harry potter machen und dann habe
ich dadurch bei ende sondern einfach
harry potter ein gebiet und dann kam so
eine box mit süßigkeiten und getränken
aus harry potter meinte aber auch ich
habe mich doch einer habe ich in den
studios habe ich in butter wir getrunken
aber schon ganz lange her
worüber das geil geil ich weiß nur so
aus ich bin so froh dass fantastic
bietet eigentlich jetzt läuft ist egal
wer was sagt eigentlich einfach gut dass
diese harry potter welt wieder das noch
so krank gefühlt 42 vor kurzem habe ich
mich viel mehr leuten jetzt am markt
sind wir nicht mehr nur die einstige
werden die darüber reden über sind alle
reden wie das cool weil die ganzen
jungen leute gucken und harry potter
nach ja nicht hier ist auf jeden fall
die besagt geboren
das ist der offizielle hogwarts style
wir anscheinend hat sie eine eule
getragen es sind müssen die das sonst
verpacken
wir machen das einfach mal auf
widerstand allein die box audio mal ein
wow da geht immer direkt stellen klar
dass schön grün also bis sieht sieht
schon nice aus fahrer stellte haye 100%
barron speciality gift wenn man verliert
marktkenner genau was kennst du davon
nein ich habe auch gesehen es gibt den
original choco fresh und lehre fertig
aber ich erwarte ich war mal kurzzeitig
noch einmal stimmt der modelle dieser
schoko forscht der quasi dem original
nachempfunden ist und kostet einfach bei
amazon 30 euro ein
ja das ist doch echt ich hab' ich habe
meinen londoner man kauft auch im
nächsten video sprechen aber auch nicht
warum ich nicht aber ich bin
zuversichtlich eine packung ist das
special gemeint war das ist aber schon
echt grün ja weil sie dir die ehre dass
dieses lila ding runter ziehen aber
schon mal sehr gut zu seinem schal
müssen
stimmt kannst du einfach wieder
reinstecken in vier oder fünf alle im
gleichen design
merkendorf das fand ich geil das ist
echt was ihr schon was gegessen
die original natürlich diese bieten
diese genau dasselbe vortage klar und
wahrscheinlich
wir haben hier okay da stehen schon die
unterschiedlichen geschmacksrichtungen
drauf
hier ich den schoko frau ok also sieht
mich ganz aus wieder für wird so richtig
gewachsen dass es max' auf ihr könnt den
ganzen die sind alle ekelhafte
süßigkeiten die wir haben - zum
lebendigen frosch den kopf abreißen oder
die anderen der diese auf englischen
dies netto zum beispiel auf lakritz
schmecken so empfehlen die weismain er
fahre das ist ganz klar ist wo man meint
sie dieses von uns wo man sie gestalten
damit zum komischen das sind doch die
keine ahnung ist ja wohl eine packende
fange erst mit der ersten sache an und
dann gucken wir uns also schrecklichste
ein bevor dann hat schmeckt
wahrscheinlich nichts wenn wir jetzt
kurz zu erwischen oder so schauen wir
uns mal habe ich hier einen rassisten
geschmacksrichtungen gibt wir haben und
schmalz regen besonders gut
hier stimmt das auch unangenehm
findest du es ist auf jeden fall wie im
buch gibt ziemlich eklige und ziemlich
hatten wir beide eine und müssen dann
raten was es ist oder willst du meine
grün grün könnte der bund opel und
anderssein und geraten
die in meine ganze wird jetzt wohne ich
habe meine auch wahr ist dass er einfach
pfeffer die auch hier bei mir haben sie
einfach nur zweifach wein gemacht aber
was haben sie bei dir ein gemeinte frage
gekommen so eine dunkelgrüne ihr euch
nun die blaue die sie zu hause könnte so
richtig geiler blaubeere und das
erschrecken wenn du glück hast 46 hier
brauchen wir fast mit wäre oder so
schafften es ist aber eigentlich ja
irgendwie ja warte ich bin kein wunder
dass ich den geschmack als nächstes
leute mir den schoko frosch der sieht
irgendwie ein bisschen spezieller aus
aber ich meine das ist schokolade hat
sollte das schon klar gehen aber dann
muss ganz kurz festhalten als sind jetzt
vier sachen hier drin
das heißt bei durch euro kostet 17 euro
teure 50 für die packung bonetti gibt es
auch in diesem jahr an diesen elbenwald
lagen ich weiß gar nicht wie viel getan
hast du es gab diesen günstigen okay
dann schauen wir mal rein
ja geil und green haben wir ohne
probleme hast du auch nein nicht
wirklich leute lieber eure wirft porsche
es gibt nicht immer so ganz leicht in
sohland großen packung verschwendung
oder verschwendung dann dass ich bis
jetzt sich die bässe süßigkeit ich in
meinem leben jemals gegessen haben aber
ich frage mich ob die echten shooter
vorschau auf knuspern aber das fahrzeug
zurück ich weiß das sehr denn ich hatte
der war einfach nur super lage in nahost
und dann haben wir sicher sagen weil die
haben mich verarscht in dem laden
ok als nächstes gedrängt oder noch eine
süße gehört erich hat das ist ein
highlight was wir als nächstes
die hat was ist von dauer auf deutsch
girlies lachs gummi schnecken banane
wenn wir nur eine mandarine sauerkirsche
bier
ich zeige euch auch noch mal kurz ihr
könnt gerne kommentieren wahrscheinlich
sind jetzt wieder leute übertrieben
sauer und sagen dass wir sofort unsere
harry potter sachen ausziehen soll das
auf deutsch heißt aber wenn die fahrer
nahmen jedes wort so ja tatsächlich weiß
wieder hund von dumbledore eltern kind
war im letzten jahr ausläuft
auch die leute so du darfst einmal diese
schuhe sind gar nicht so hart und so
sehen die dinge aus leute mehreren und
die so herzlos haribo colorado
diese mischung und das sind so vor denen
lakritz sachen die die kassen diese
diese aber das ist einfach nur grüße und
gelb drin und der sitzung 5
dass wir haben alle das ist ein gutes
[Musik]
diese kleine vierecke die mit dem sie
beim arzt oder sowas
wieso weiß beweisen konnten ist ein
original so schmeckt das nimmt wo kommen
wir zum finalen
so gespannt ist doch okay was ist das
golden butter scotch tierfutter
wahrscheinlich oder 4
weil die flasche ist richtig geil leute
mir ist aufgefallen dass hat jana mir
schon mal geschenkt aber ich weiß nicht
mehr wie es schmeckt also das muss man
sagen es schon wirklich cool gemacht
ja leute was man sehen der caravan
gekommen war
das riecht geil wille karamell
gemischten denkmal an batterien oder
beim restart ist nicht gut aber
irgendwie stimmt ok kommen probieren wow
das ist krass mit aber auch lecker
irgendwie das soll dies schon ab süß und
dieses also waffeln im abgang schmeckt
es nicht an sondern es ist schon lustig
dass zu probieren es ist so ein harry
potter hat das irgendwie aber in ja
nicht jeden tag da bringt jetzt auch mal
ganz ehrlich sagen an dieser stelle also
das auf keinen fall das wird jetzt nicht
irgendwie so ich denke zwar auch keine
kohle aber es würde jetzt nicht so in
die cola ersetzen so anschaut und was
finden lebt müssen wir deswegen ist
schon geil ist ich finde auch also aber
wenn man wirklich so diese ganzen sachen
so sieht und feiert unserer inter macht
es schon sinn sich das so das ist
natürlich trotzdem über teuer
es war also es ist eher so ein erlebnis
als geschmackliche sullivan ist es er
sei kein taktieren hat irgendwie als
komiker in jedem fall würde ich mich
selber dann für dieses wunderbare harry
potter erlebnis zusammen mit ihm freuen
sich auf der mal wieder anruft sagt so
lassen hält
habt ihr noch netto harry potter ideen
schreibt sie in die kommentare ansonsten
sehen wir uns beim nächsten mal und bis
dahin tschüss